- I'm here with the very
funny Ricky Gervais,
who I just learned was, once upon a time,
also a budding rock star.
Okay, so can you explain this photo to me?
- All I can say is, I was 20 years old.
Look at that!
- Sexy.
- And I think when (laughs),
if I look at that, people
think I'm embarrassed
about how I looked then.
No, I'm embarrassed about how I look now.
- I would never be embarrassed
about how you looked then!
You looked like a frigin' rockstar!
- (laughs) And people
say, "What happened?"
I'll tell you what happened,
beer and pizza, that's what happened,
and I don't regret one,
I don't regret one.
- [Kelly] That's like
people always attack me.
They're like, "What has she been doin?"
Well, obviously, eating and
not working out. (laughs)
I'm like, "It doesn't
take a rocket scientist
to figure out someone
just maybe has a glass
of wine every night,
and is like, 'No, I won't
go to the gym.'" (laughs)
- No, and people say,
"Oh, if you gave up beer
and pizza, you'd live longer."
But I only wanna live
longer to eat more pizza
and drink more beer.
- Is it real living, is the question.
- Exactly, yeah!
(Both laughing)
- All right, and so, how did
you get started in music?
I didn't know that like,
is that your first love?
- I guess so.
I mean, growing up I
loved science and nature,
and then when maybe 13, 14
and I've got into music.
And then when I was a teenager
I discovered David Bowie,
and then I went to university
and I actually did sciences.
I got into university to study sciences,
but then I realized, no,
I want to join a band.
I've come to university to join a band
and I changed to philosophy,
which was a lot less
hours a week than science.
(Kelly laughing)
- One's an easier degree.
- (laughs) Yeah, the rock star's degree.
And I started a band
and we got signed, and it was
over as quick as it started.
My rock career was one year,
one year long. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Hey, that's longer
than some people get, so.